[Música]
olá sou eduardo esse funcionário de uma
multinacional que decidiu seguir o seu
propósito
mas esse não será um teste apenas com o
lado bom dessa história pra vocês me
conhecerem melhor como apresentação de
algumas coisas que eu gosto
o meia viajar e conhecer novas culturas
já estive em quase 40 países e com o
tempo quanto mais diferente era o país
mas eu gostava também sou um apaixonado
por projetos sociais
acredito que todos somos capazes de
tornar o mundo um pouco melhor
isso é muito ligado à minha criação
lembro que quando eu tinha uns 12 anos
meu pai me deu desce a estréia no
mercado quer comprar batalha não lembro
o troco resolvi comprar comida para o
pessoal que ficava em frente ao mercado
e cheguei em casa e expliquei pra ele
porque não tinha o troco e ele ficou
super feliz mas lembro que ele falou
quero ver você fazendo caridade com o
seu dinheiro no futuro também sou do
interior do estado do rio grande do sul
e quando me formei na escola e fui para
porto alegre fazer faculdade de
administração embora não tivesse a menor
idéia de qual caminho gostaria de seguir
logo no início da faculdade nasceu uma
paixão por bolsa de valores
investimentos
quando eu e meu irmão começamos a
investir na bolsa com 600 reais que
tinham juntado moeda
comecei a estudar muito sobre o assunto
em maio de 2009 e também os mais jovens
brasileiros a vencer o prémio nacional
do fundo investe simulador de mercado de
capitais com apenas 19 anos e competindo
com mais de 100 mil pessoas e os fez eu
achei que deveria seguir carreira no
setor financeiro
procurei em estágio na área em menos de
três meses recebi a proposta de
efetivação
era mais um indício que esse setor é o
que deveria seguir
porém após dois anos de empresa eu fui
para o nepal onde eu fiquei cinco
semanas fazendo um trabalho voluntário
com 33 crianças e de aula de inglês numa
escolinha do vilarejo
quando estava escolhendo o país pra ir
peguei ele se desligar de baixo pra cima
do continente asiático que antes
gostaria de ir
em primeiro lugar era afeganistão
achei que seria um pouco perigoso na
época a chance de matar minha mãe de
preocupação era muito alta então acabei
optando pelo nepal que era um dos cinco
países menos desenvolvidos da ásia
sempre falo que o nepal foi divisor de
águas na minha vida porque me ensinou a
valorizar mais e a reclamar - teve um
dia que estava em uma das meninas do
orfanato no pátio
ela apontou para uma estrela que ela
acelera o pai dela
depois apontou para uma outra estrela
falando que ela outras ela era a mãe
dela
depois apontou na terceira estrela plano
seria eu quando retornasse ao brasil
essas estrelas que estavam lá era que os
pais delas tinham falecido num acidente
de carro
essa menina também era responsável por
cozinhar para todas as demais crianças
do orfanato com apenas 12 anos
em nenhum momento cultural reclamando da
vida mesmo tendo bem mais motivos do que
eu
ao chegar ao brasil ea empresa onde
trabalhava eu fui promovido depois de um
ano e meio promovido novamente porém a
estratégia da empresa tinha mudado e
objetivo do financeiro naquele momento
era gerar fluxo de caixa mais rápido pra
empresa pagar as dívidas dela tem assim
eu voltando do nepal escutando isso nos
fez perceber que meu propósito tinha
mudado e que eu precisava trabalhar com
pessoas e projetos sociais
mas eu sozinho nem fazer a mínima
diferença no mundo mas com mais pessoas
ajudando é conseguir realizar o meu
sonho de tornar o mundo um pouco melhor
pelo menos para as pessoas que a gente
consegue atingir
com isso funec change do bem uma agência
de viagens que conecta voluntários com
diversos projetos sociais ao redor do
mundo atuando nas mais variadas causas
como educação empoderamento feminino
proteção à infância e os animais e eu
podia terminar meu teste aqui já e essa
seria mais uma história do jovem que
largou sua carreira de sucesso para
seguir o seu propósito e com isso ele
foi a pessoa mais realizada deste mundo
talvez você vai escutar alguma história
romântica e similares assim
porém eu estaria sendo injusto com vocês
se eu compartilhasse tudo
tenho até hoje enfrenta por ter seguido
o meu propósito por oito meses
trabalhei nesse meu emprego anterior e
muitas vezes durante o dia ea noite
também
e quando chegava em casa eu trabalhava
na criação do exchange do bem por mim é
muito pouco não foram poucas as noites
que entrei noite adentro o que acordei
de madrugada pra ter reunião com o
pessoal da ásia após fazer uma reserva
financeira em março de 2016 eu pedi
demissão com os planos de inaugurar
empresa em junho
no início de qualquer empresa que você
mais tem abundância são problemas em seu
incertezas dinheiro você precisa
economizar para economizar contra tem um
freelancer que me prometeu site em junho
mas ele por uma ele falou que o site não
ficaria pronto em junho apenas em agosto
tudo bem eu pensei são dois meses vou
aproveitar esses dois meses o viajar
pelo continente africano conheça novos
projetos novos países entender melhor
como eu posso ajudá los
voltei ao brasil em agosto e o site era
ter ficado pronto no mesmo mês ficou
pronto apenas em dezembro e não
funcionava para o celular
para completar esse filho é separar o
time responder
mesmo já tendo pago boa parte do valor
então eu tive que contratar uma nova
imprensa
para começar o site do zero novamente
também esperando o site pronto em agosto
um amigo meu aceitou o desafio de entrar
na sociedade sabendo que no início
também não ia ter salário e pediu
demissão do trabalho dele então a
empresa virou eu ele cada um trabalhando
do seu quarto com uma página no facebook
tentando vender uma viagem para o que n
áfrica do sul nepal índia era difícil no
primeiro ano viajaram três pessoas
connosco dois eram nossos amigos que a
gente deu desconto e uma terceira pessoa
tinha visto uma reportagem sobre a
enchente do bem e foi para o quênia
ela construiu uma cozinha para o
campeonato que ela estava ajudando a
gente ficou superfeliz
a primeira voluntária já causando grande
impacto social
posteriormente a gente descobriu que o
diretor de seu finado tinha
superfaturada
e com isso a primeira decepção ela
retornou uma semana antes do previsto e
devolvemos a ela o valor pago por essa
semana
apesar das coisas não estar indo bem
foi importante ter acontecido isso logo
no início para criarmos uma política
ainda mais rigorosa de como escolher os
melhores projetos e depois disso nunca
mais aconteceu antes com o site
finalmente pronto um ano depois que eu
pedi demissão começaram a surgir novos
voluntários
quando voluntário pagava passagem aérea
vista a gente para selar a passagem do
voluntário nosso cartão de crédito
pessoal e assim utilizar o dinheiro para
outras despesas
fiquei 11 meses sem salário e meu
primeiro salário foi mil reais
mesmo tendo virado presidente diretor
comercial diretor de marketing e diretor
financeiro estagiário também para dar
conta de tudo isso o ritmo de trabalho
aumentou para no mínimo 80 horas por
semana e até hoje estou 24 horas
conectado por dia na empresa
comecei a escutar que ora catholic mas
era a única pessoa que sabia que tinha
dez mil reais na conta e 50 mil reais em
despesas nos próximos meses por ter
ficado todo esse tempo sem salário
comecei a deixar de fazer muitas coisas
também por medo de gastar pois até então
a empresa não tinha dado certo
isso fez com que eu me isolar se no meu
quarto que também virou meu escritório e
eu que sempre fui uma criança tímida e
com as viagens eu consegui superar a
timidez
aos 28 anos o texto é uma pessoa bem
mais introvertida novamente após quase
dois anos de empresa ela finalmente deu
uma virada e conseguimos conquistar
vários novos voluntários em todo o
brasil
com isso hoje aos poucos vou retomando
minha vida social novamente e voltar a
fazer atividades físicas e também tive
que deixar de fazer afinal o funcional
na entrada mas o meu orçamento
se alguém acha agora que eu vou falar
que não vale a pena seguir o propósito
está muito enganado
o propósito foi o que me deu energia
para ter encarado essa fase tanto outros
desafios
sem nunca ter pensado em desistir e hoje
após ver o que conseguimos levar
atendimento médico para o vilarejo no
interior do nepal que construímos um
sistema de drenagem para um orfanato em
gana e que também pagamos o primeiro ano
de faculdade para uma das meninas
deserto nato e que diversos outros
projetos já tiveram melhorias graças aos
voluntários exchange do bem
eu tenho certeza que tudo valeu a pena
você pudesse finalizar com uma dica pra
vocês seria para buscar um propósito em
tudo que vocês vão fazer na vida
nós não esqueçam que a jornada não será
nada fácil
obrigada
[Música]